حيث يوجد الزميل عمر حلبي عمر قضيه
اللاجئين مثل ما قلنا اثارت الكثير من
الجدل كيف
تعيش غازي عن تاب هذه الاجواء اجواء فوز
اردوغان في هذه الانتخابات في مقابل فوز
المعارضه التي تعاهدت باعاده اللاجئين الى
دوالهم في اقل من عام
هكذا تعيش وسيله على هذا النحو تماما انا
الطرق ان ابتعد عن المكان الذي كنت فيه في
النشره السابقه نحو خمسه كيلو متر ووصلت
الى هذا المكان طمعا في ان استطيع ان اسمع
صوتي على الاقل واسمعكم ايضا لكن اينما
وليت وجهك هنا في غازي عنتاب سرينا طوابير
السيارات المحتفله الاهالي الذين نزلوا
الى الشوارع محتفلين بفوز مرشحهم الرئيس
التركي الرئيس التركي
رسمي رجب طيب اردوغان عموما وسيله
الاحتفالات حاشده في العديد من المناطق في
معظم ميادين غازي عنتاب امام مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه وسط المدينه عند منطقه
الجامعه في العديد من المناطق وليس هم
وحدهم من يحتفلون بفوز الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان انما يشاركهم هذه الفرحه ايضا
اللاجئون وخصوصا الشريحه الاكبر من
اللاجئين اللاجئون السوريون نحن راينا في
في الميادين مئات من السوريين يحتفلون
جنبا الى جنب مع
مناصري تحالف الجمهور الحاكم بفوزه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ونرى ايضا هنا
سيارات من خلال ارقامها نعلم بانها سيارات
للاجئين السوريين بالتالي هي فرحه كانت
تنوم عن مدى
مكانه هؤلاء حتى استطاعوا ان يحققوا او
منتظره بالاحرى ان صح التعبير منتظروه
من اجل ان يفوز مرشحهم كما تفضل زميلنا
احمد ولدين هم مضطر ان ينتظروا الشوطين
اثنين مليئين بالتنافس بان الديه حتى
تمكنوا اخيرا من مشاهده مرشحهم يفوز
تمكنوا من ان يتغلبوا على خطابين خاطبهما
بهما
مرشح تحالف الجمهور مرشح تحالف الشعب
المعارض كماس الاول في قضيه
الزلزال ولكن عندما لم يستجيبوا له
صوتوا بكثافه لصالح طيب اردوغان مرشح
تحالف الجمهور الحاكم
قالوا هم بانهم تعرضوا للاساءه من مناصر
تحالف الشعب المعارض ثم بعد ذلك كان
وخاطبهم كمال بخطاب اخر يمس بدرجه كبيره
وخاطبهم بقضيه اللاجئين غازي عنتاب هي من
اكبر المدن في الجنوب التركي ومن اكبر
المدن في عموم تركيا التي تضم لاجئين
خصوصا من اللاجئين السوريين
[موسيقى]
خاطبهم حتى يكسب اصواتهم ويستميل اصواتهم
الناخبه لكن رغم ذلك وسيله غازي عنتاب في
الجوله الثانيه صوتت اكثر
لصالح رجب طيب اردوغان باكثر باربع نقاط
مئويه في الجوله الاولى صوتت ب 59.8 في
المئه في هذه الجوله صوت تقريبا
64 في المئه لصالح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بينما تراج اسود المنافس كمال كلش
دار اوغلو مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض عموما
نحن من خلال عمليه التصويت التي كنا ايضا
قد شاهدناها قبيله نتائج الاقتراع عندما
كنا نرى الرجال كبار السن وهم يجتهدون في
الهروله الى مناطق الى مراكز الاقتراع حتى
يدلوا اصواتهم هذا كان يدل في الحقيقه
وسيله على مدى حرص هؤلاء ان يدلوا
باصواتهم
لصالح مرشحهم ومعروف طبعا هنا اقول مرشحهم
لان غازي عنتاب معروف عنها بانها صوت
تقليدي لصالح تحالف الجمهور الحاكم ولصالح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان غازي عنتاب
بالاضافه الى العديد من الولايات الموجوده
هنا في الجنوب التركي والتي تضم لاجئين
وخصوصا من اللاجئين السوريين فيها تجمعات
كبيره من اللاجئين صوتوا في هذه الجوله
الثانيه بنسبه اكبر عن الجوله الاولى
لصالح تحالف الجمهور الحاكم ولصالح الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وبالتالي لم
يستجيبوا لا في الجوله الاولى عندما فاجات
هذه الولايات مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض
فسودت لصالح رجب طيب اردوغان وفي هذه
الجوله كذلك تجاهل خطابه بخصوص اللاجئين
وصوتوا بنسبه مرتفعه اكثر عن الجوله
الماضيه لصالح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان طبعا لانهم لم يكونوا يقتنعوا
بخصوص خطاب كمال اجدار اوغلو المتعلق
بقضيه اللاجئين لانهم لانهم يصفونه بانه
كان خطاب كراهيه وخطاب عنصري وخطاب لم
يتعودوا عليه هم كانوا يعتقدون ويؤمنون
بالخطاب الذي كان يخاطبهم به الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قبل يومين او
ثلاثه ايام من الان تحديدا عندما زار
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان خاطب
انصاره اكثر من 100 الف من انصاره في هذه
المدينه وقال نحن ضد خطاب الكراهيه
واعادهم مره اخرى رغم انها كانت جوله
حاسمه في هذه الجوله الثانيه اعاد وذكر
مره اخرى قبيل يوم الاقتراع بمبدا الذي
يدين به تحالف الجمهور الحاكم وهو ما بين
قوسين مبدا الانصار والمهاجرين لذلك كل
كل الاصوات التقليديه هنا
ذهبت بالفعل او هل نقل معظمها ذهبت بالفعل
لصالحي الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ربما تكون هنالك شريحه تؤمن بعوده
اللاجئين لكن حسب رؤيه الحكومه بموضوع
العوده الطوعيه بموضوعا لا يكون هناك خطاب
كراهيه وعنصريه ينعكس على الشارع وهذا ما
شاهدنا الان عكسه كما قلت لك عندما راينا
الاحتفالات
لاجئين وناخبين اتراك يحتفلون جنبا الى
جنبي فوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
رغم ان من برامج الحكومه اصلا موضوع
العوده الطوعيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وسوف يطردهم من هذه البلاد عموما
وسيله هي حاله فرحه كبيره بعد ان تمكنت
غازي عنتاب والولايات الاخرى المعنيه
بقضيه الزلزال وبقضيه اللاجئين في ثمار
اصواتها